you know I'm a little bit torn there
because I think Hollywood shouldn't
necessarily be a platform for any
message but then I also believe it's
foolish to imagine that it doesn't you
know from from the very basic of cutting
out smoking for movies and what that did
to views toward people who smoke you
know I think we're moving beyond I like
to think the token gay character in
movies and TV shows but I don't think
we're quite there yet but I think that's
important to show that even in
mainstream movies to have gay and
lesbian characters who are normalized
they're not the token gay character they
are another character in that movie and
I like the idea of sort of plot lines
within TV and film that deal with gay
men and women but don't necessarily
focus on that as a soul issue because
then I I think it sort of creates a
caricature of what this is supposed to
be so I I do think to an extent
Hollywood does hold some
responsibilities but you know homophobia
exists in that industry like any other
while you know your agent or your
publicist can be gay don't expect to
sign on to a movie as an open gay person
and expect a big paycheck yeah I think
both parties are going to point fingers
it's very easy for me as a movie goer to
say Hollywood the institution needs to
change their ways but I also think if
they put a openly gay character in a
major motion picture I don't think it
would perform as well as the BA at the
box office so I think we do need to take
small steps to reach that that end-all
goal it's not going to happen overnight
and I think it'd be foolish to assume so
but you know I think the American public
does still have this cringe mentality
when it comes to the idea of gay men and
women playing leading roles or roles
where they are the gay character
all the way to Hollywood that is fearful
of even opening up that possibility
because the investment is so large and
you know studio wants to make that bet